the 13th annual fighters-only world mma
awards will take place friday december
10th in las vegas and opening up that
show
is our good friend ashba
thanks for joining us thank you for
having me you were doing this kind of
stuff all over the place you are
everywhere and we were just listening to
your new song that was fantastic yeah
thank you uh you are also very soon
going to the frozen tundra in green bay
yeah and you're going to be opening up
with the national anthem yes i'm going
to be playing the national anthem
december 12th
which is going to be very cold in green
bay it's packers against the bears but
uh i just found out it was the frozen
tundra so okay
and you're gonna find out why when you
get there
it is cold there are you gonna be out on
the field or whatever yes well i don't
know
originally yes but because of covid they
didn't have me just off the field things
have really taken off for you over the
last little while and i know for us it
seems like wow that's amazing but for
you it's like years and years of hard
work yes uh tell us what's unfolded
recently geez after i left guns and
roses i started a new project called
ashva and it's just i i wanted to
basically
get re-inspired as an artist but
hopefully find a way to inspire a bunch
of young kids to pick up an instrument
and i am kind of colliding the worlds of
rock guitar in with electronic dance
music and we just simply call it guitar
dance music gdm
it's going great for you too
now what will you be doing at the mma
awards i am going to be playing my new
single which is a remake of the classic
italian song bella ciao okay that's what
i think we heard coming into this yes
yes and they just they called me they
want me to present an award and i'm a
big mma fan so i i'm excited do you know
which award you're presenting i don't
yet yeah because here's here's some of
them that are going to be presented at
this uh fight of the year knockout of
the year
uh it's black tie you got a black tie
you got a tuxedo i gotta go buy one
uh you'll be opening things up uh with
your song this is really exciting this
is gonna be on uh december 21st nine
o'clock
um on espn plus yes
maybe i'll steal a tie from joe or dana
yeah
i got i got a tie i can lend you for
sure yeah what do you have my wife right
there in the video oh my goodness this
is the video here that is the video i
love the sound and i love the video it's
beautiful
tell us about them
oh
gavin
i haven't seen him in a while but i get
i got to give a good shout out to adam
hunter he's a he's a phenomenal comedian
and he originally uh gave me a call
about this and it just transpired into
me opening up with belichick so i'm
excited that is really cool what else is
coming up in 2022 what do you expect um
gosh uh we're gonna be putting out a lot
of music so hopefully touring i want to
hit all the big festivals and that's the
goal so yeah yeah and anybody any where
we can see you in las vegas anytime soon
or um
yeah i'm going to be doing another award
show at allegiant stadium called the
vegas one awards on december i think
29th okay you opened up a golden knights
game i did i played the anthem at the
knights game and that that is an
electric atmosphere too yeah which which
compares the guns and roses concert one
of your concerts or a golden knights the
knife
hometown uh
uh thrilled for all the success you're
enjoying well deserved and appreciate
you being here today and uh enjoy the
mma awards thanks hoping things are fair
the annual fighters-only world mma
awards